Ronald starts off this hour in Effingham
Illinois i Ronald welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hello hi how you doing
better than I deserve how can I help my
property I'm in step seven a lot of
property and I'm wanting to give it to
my girlfriend or sell it to my
girlfriend and her daughter but they're
deep in debt they're going to rent it
from me until they make the payments
plus the upgrades on it and then they
can happen I don't want to probably
admit I want them to have it is that a
good position to put them in or not
you're going to give this lady that
you're dating a house I'm going to sell
it to them actually but they're gonna
pay it as ramped it's like a rent own I
own the property it's in my name they're
going to pay me a ring on it
and then when the rent equals the amount
that I paid for it
plus all expenses on it then I'm going
to deed it to them is that a good deal
or a pat you okay that is what's called
a land contract or a rent-to-own
depending on how you structure the legal
documents under it a land contract is
you have a contract with them it says
when you pay payments equal to this and
monthly payment equal to this interest
rate equal to this the total of the
payments equals y then we deed you the
property the property is in her name or
in your name until then and it is a
contract for deed a land contract
sometimes called
you can do it that way or you can lease
it to someone with an option to purchase
it their option to purchase it would
reduce each year that you let them lease
it and it'd be the same kind of a thing
that's probably a little cleaner and
probably a better idea in general so
let's say I had a I was going to lease a
property someone with an option to
purchase if they did not pay the lease
payment their option would be void and
you evicted them like a tenant in a
worst-case scenario
in a land contract in most states you
have to go through a foreclosure to get
them out and now all that sounds weird
because we're talking about your
girlfriend which also sounds weird that
we're doing this deal with it sounds
like you're doing a long-term deal with
your girlfriend it's it's gonna be Oh
probably seven five seven years yeah I
mean your plan is to never marry this
girl to date her forever and let her be
your renter my problem is I don't think
they can ever pay for it I don't think
it'll ever happen guess where I'm asked
and I think that's putting I care it and
throw them but they can't never obtain
okay then why would you do that to
somebody you care about that's that's my
problem
yeah it's not and you're not blessing
you're not blessing them with this
transaction you're cursing them that's
why I'm thanking no that's the problem
at the core of this and you just got to
mix in this whole relationship part of
it which it just gets weird I mean
you're collecting rent from a girl
you're kissing I mean that's we that
just gets strange you know and you're
gonna do this over an extended period of
time not just until we get married you
know so okay III I mean it's just very
it becomes really really awkward it can
be done but it just becomes it requires
very very strong emotional and spiritual
condition of both of you to be able to
maintain proper boundaries and be able
to go okay in this conversation I am
your renter and in this conversation I'm
your girlfriend and not let those two
things jump back and forth it takes a
special kind of person to be able to
pull that one off
and in you know for on your case in this
conversation I'm your boyfriend in this
conversation I'm your landlord and I got
to tell you I treat my renters different
than I do my wife and I mean as well I
should as well I should so I'm not mean
to my renters I don't mean that but I
mean it's just a different come it's a
different transaction it's a different
conversation and that's what's going to
make this awkward as crud for you man so
I'm probably just not going to do this
deal I probably just let her have her
life and you date her and let that
relationship progress as best you can
and if you ever were to get married
someday then obviously you would provide
her a home as part of being her husband
and the two of you would make decisions
about your home and that kind of a thing
so that would all be fine that's all
cool but I'm I just I I think you're
gonna get into weirdness here and you're
probably going to end up with a bad
girlfriend deal and a bad tenant deal I
both that's what I'm afraid of
especially since you think she can
handle it so we're walking into a
situation where we know she's gonna
struggle and that's you know double
asking for it so I'm probably gonna pass
if I'm you based on what you told me hey
thanks for the call